>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM,
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM NEW YORK CITY.
MY ANKLE IN MOMENTS.
BUT FIRST TOOK YOU FIND YOURSELF
LOOKING AROUND AT ALL THE
DESTRUCTION WROUGHT WONDERING,
HOW COULD THINGS GET WORSE THAN
THEY ARE UNDER BIDEN?
BE SURE TO REMEMBER THAT HIS
NUMBER TWO IS KAMALA HARRIS.
TONIGHT, SHE SAT DOWN WITH DANA
BASH IN A INTERVIEW FOLLOWING
THE JOBS DECISION AT THE COURTS.
IF YOU ARE EXPECTED ANYTHING
PROFOUND FROM THE FORMER LAWYER
AND SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBER, YOU
CAME TO THE WRONG INTERVIEW.
>> Vice President Harris: I'M
SHOCKED BUT IT IS ONE THING WHEN
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT IS ONE THING WHEN IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS.
AND BY JUST ACTUALLY TURNED AND
I CANNOT BELIEVE IT I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT AS A PARENT.
I THOUGHT UPENDED AS A GOD
PARENT, AS AN AUNT OF PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN AND A WOMAN MYSELF.
AS A DOCTOR OF A WOMAN.
AND A GRANDDAUGHTER OF A WOMAN.
>> Laura: A LOT OF REPEATING.
AT LEAST SHE CAN IDENTIFY WOMAN
NOW.
IT SHE ALSO SHARED A BIG CONCERN
OF HERS.
THAT MAIN WILL BE ABLE TO KNOCK
UP GIRLS INTO AND FORCE THEM
INTO ABORTIONS.
>> Vice President Harris: IF
YOU ARE A PARENT OF SONS, THINK
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEAN FOR THE
LIFE OF YOUR SON AND WHAT THAT
WILL MEAN IN TERMS OF THE
CHOICES HE WILL HAVE.
>> Laura: WHAT?
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT NEWS TO
COME OUT OF THIS INTERVIEW CAME
NEAR THE END.
CONNECTICUT THE NEAR TIMES IS
OUT WITH A STORY HEADLINE BIDEN
ACT BY DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED --
BONE TO TAKE YES FOR AN ANSWER,
NOTING, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
TRYING TO TAMP DOWN SPECULATIONS
TO.
WHILE AGENCY PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
BRISTLING AT THE PERSISTENT
QUESTIONS.
AND FOR BETTER OR WORSE, THEY
TROTTED OUT, BLOOD
TO.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT
ELECTION.
>> Vice President Harris: JOE
BIDEN IS RUNNING FOR REELECTION
AND I WILL BE HIS TICKET MATE,
FULL STOP.
>> Laura: AS IF REPUBLICANS
NEEDED ANY MORE GOOD NEWS.
JOINING ME IS THE OPINION EDITOR
AS WELL AS THE EDITOR IN LARGE
PART.
AS WELL AS THE HOST OF
OVERTURNING ROE ON FOX NATION
TO.
BOTH OF YOU ARE FOX
CONTRIBUTORS.
CHARLIE WITH BIDEN ABROAD, WE
ARE GETTING A SNEAK PEEK AT WHAT
THAT MESSAGING FROM KAMALA IN
THAT ADMINISTRATION LOOKS LIKE.
IT AIN'T PRETTY.
>> IT IS NOT AND YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
WHEN YOU THINK IT CAN'T GET
WORSE, IS GET SOMEBODY WHO HAD
SPENT YEARS IN THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND OF
COURSE HAS UNDERPERFORMED AT
EVERY SINGLE STEP OF THE WAY.
BUT THIS IS WHAT YOU GET WHEN
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO PUTS
SOMEBODY BASED ON THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN AND THE THEIR GENDER
AND NO OTHER QUALIFICATIONS
WHATSOEVER.
YOU WIND UP WITH THIS.
>> Laura: BEN WHAT ABOUT THE
COMMENTS ABOUT BOYS?
HOW THIS IS GOING TO AFFECT
BOYS?
MAYBE I'M NOT GETTING WHAT SHE
MEANT.
BUT IT CERTAINLY SOUNDED LIKE
BOYS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO BE
RESPONSIBLE, MORE RESPONSIBLE
NOW TO.
THIS IS ODD.
>> THE HORROR THAT ACTUALLY TAKE
RESPONSE BUILDING FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AS OPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
PAYEE GIRL TO GO AWAY AND HAVE
AN ABORTION.
THIS IS HORRENDOUS AND
DISTURBING BUT IT IS ALSO SO
TYPICAL.
THE THING I LOVE ABOUT, HERE'S
IS THAT SHE IS TOO DUMB TO
REALLY HIDE ANY OF THIS, WHAT
THE LEFT WANTS YOU TO HYDE PARK.
SHE JUST THROWS IT OUT THERE AND
SHE CACKLES AFTER IT.
AND THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
IT.
IT IS LIKE, YOU WILL HAVE TO
TELL YOUR SONS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RESPONSIBLE
IF THEY GO OUT AND SLEEP WITH
SOMEONE AND HAVE A BABY.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO KILL IT AND WALK AWAY.
ISN'T THAT HORRIBLE EVENT THAT
IS THE SORT OF THING THAT SHE
WOULD BRING THAT ANY KIND OF
TICKET IN 2,024th.
DEFECTED SHE IS INVITED THAT SHE
IS GOING TO BE ON THE TICKET IN
2024, I'M SURE IT ENCOURAGES ALL
OF THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
CONCERNED AT THE MOMENT.
DON'T WORRY.
THEY GOT THESE THINGS UNDER
CONTROL.
>> Laura: PETE BUTTEGIEG IS
LIKE, I'M LOOKING PRETTY GOOD
NOW ON MY COMMUTER BY CHARLIE
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THE AUNT,
A LOT WHICH WAS THIS
LATEBREAKING EXCHANGE THAT CAME
AROUND 6:30.
BETWEEN BIDEN AND MCCRONE AT THE
G7 WHERE THEY ARE DISCUSSING OUR
RELIANCE ON THE UAE AND BY
THEIR'S FORTHCOMING TRIP TO
SAUDI ARABIA FOR OIL.
WATCH.
[INDISTINCT]
>> Laura: CHARLIE, I GUESS HE
HAS SOME COMPETITION HERE.
WHAT IS THIS?
IS HE BRIEFING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ON THE FACT
THAT THE MIDDLE EAST IS
BASICALLY AT MAX CAPACITY NOW
AND BIDEN IS LIKE, WOW, HE SEEMS
TO BE REALLY INTERESTED.
SOMEONE IS GIVING ME INFORMATION
I CAN USE.
WHAT OF THAT?
CHARLIE CRIST.
>> Charlie: IT IS HARD TO BLAME
HIM TAKE HUNTER BIDEN WAS NOT
AVAILABLE TO BE GIVING IT ALL OF
HIS EXPERT ADVICE.
ON ENERGY POLICY.
HE HAS TO GO SOMEWHERE.
BUT HONESTLY, AND THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT FROM THE WHOLE THING
WITH KAMALA HARRIS.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN'S CHICKENS
COMING HOME TO ROOST.
YOU HAVE AN ADMISSION THAT IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF ITS STEP ON
ENERGY POLICY.
THEY HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THEY
CAN AND AN ACT OF WAR ON ENERGY
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU WANT UP
WITH AND IT WENT UP WITH THIS
HORRIFYING.
THERE AND JOE BIDEN RETURN INTO
THE MIDDLE EAST WITH BAKING FOR
OIL TO MAKE LIFE A LITTLE BIT
MORE LIVABLE AND THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Laura: HE IS SAYING DRILL,
BABY, DRILL.
THEY WILL HAVE TO PRODUCE SOME
OIL BUT I WANTED TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM CNN ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE GOP.
WATCH.
>> IT IS HARD TO MENTIONED THAT
REPUBLICAN PARTY SURVIVING THAT.
BETWEEN ANTIABORTION LGBT --
ANTI-LGBTQ BOOK BANNING,
ANTIDEMOCRACY COMING, ADD ALL OF
THE REGRESSIVE [BLEEP] GARBAGE,
SORRY, TO THIS, I DON'T TAKE
THAT BACK.
ADD IT ALTOGETHER AND I WHO IS
LEFT IN FUTURE GENERATIONS TO BE
DRAWN TO THIS PARTY.
>> THE AP REPORTED THAT WE --
THE GOP HAS ADDED A MILLION NEW
VOTERS.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT THERE.
BUT WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE I GUESS THEY WON'T HAVE
AS MANY ABORTIONS AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK THAT IS A GOOD
THING.
>> LAURA I HAVE KNOWN S.E. FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE.
I DISAGREE WITH HER AND I THINK
SHE IS WRONG.
I THINK THE EXCHANGE, THE GOP
HAS MADE HERE, IN TERMS OF
MOVING MORE ON THE CULTURAL SIDE
TOWARD THIS RISING NUMBER OF
HISPANIC IMMIGRANT DIVERSE GROUP
OF VOTERS WHO ARE NOT JUST
BROUGHT INTO THE COALITION OF
2020 BUT I THINK IN THAT
REPUBLICAN COALITION GOING
FORWARD, ON THESE CULTURE MORE
ISSUES TO THREE ISSUES SHE CITES
ARE A HUGE NUMBER, A MUCH BIGGER
NUMBER THAN THE NUMBER OF
SUBURBAN WEALTHY WOMEN WHO WERE
ARE GOING TO BE PRO-ABORTION
THAT YOU KNOW, SHOUT YOUR
ABORTION KIND OF VOTERS WHO ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE CONVINCED TO
VOTE FOR MITT ROMNEY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT WAS A
LONG TERM PROPOSITION.
I THINK THE AUTOPSY THAT WAS
DONE IN 2012 PLUS ABOUT THE
PARTY THAT WAS DEAD AND THIS NEW
COALITION, THIS ONE THAT I THINK
IS FAR MORE PASSIONATE THAT HAS
A LOT MORE GOING FOR IT AND IS
ABOUT THE AMERICAN FAMILY, ABOUT
ALL THOSE ABOVE ALL THINGS BEGIN
TO SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS A BENEFICIAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE COUNTRY.
MOVE AWAY FROM THE HARSH
ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE OF THE PAST
AND ONE THAT ACTUALLY ME
FAMILIES WHERE THE ART AND
PRIORITIZES THE ISSUES AS THEY
SEE THEM AS OPPOSED TO THE WAY
THAT THE NEW YORK TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD BELIEVES THEY
OUGHT TO SEE TEMPO.
>> Laura